when Jordan
[Applause]
right on man it's beautiful welcome to
fat man I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith I'm
mark Renard hey happy Comic Con
everybody it is Saturday night we're
here at the American comedy club and all
of it I can't imagine is anybody in the
audience that's not partaking in
comic-con in some way or another we're
all here for San Diego comic-con 2017
and it has been a glorious one but more
glorious day today was [ __ ] massive
there's news coming out right now even
as I was walking out here I still read
and [ __ ] they showed the Avengers
footage in Hall H like two hours ago I
didn't see it you didn't see it now you
didn't have to because neeki
[ __ ] shot it and put it up on
Twitter and I watched it and [ __ ]
yeah I knew a beautiful world we live
and I don't have to wait in a line and
[ __ ] like that
my kid was begging me today she's like
take me to Hall H I was like are you
[ __ ] kidding me
if you wait ten minutes there's some
crafty people out there man we'll be
able to watch it and it was fantastic
and hearing it on the phone he can
barely hear because the audience is
drowning it out but the visuals were
[ __ ] stunning man like I've watched
them blow the roof off then somebody
else put up hidden camera on Black
Panther which brought everybody to their
feet yeah I mean that seems to have been
the story yeah right was I guess Thor
Ragnarok it's going to be awesome we
know that looks amazing
Avengers if any words going to be
amazing and then [ __ ] Black Panther
people lost the goddamn minds and and
this is also a day where Warner Brothers
was like look at the [ __ ] justice like
look how badass Aquaman is
they have one of the most metal hardcore
like heavy metal shots I've seen in a
movie in my entire life
his Aquaman stabbing a para demon into
the [ __ ] chest in the heart
landing through a building [ __ ]
walking off and flipping his hair back
like a job oh my god it was dope and it
was like once again use like I can tell
to Zack Snyder movie somebody's sliding
down a building and this guy is all red
oh yeah just signature move but I didn't
give a [ __ ] because that hair flip like
that made it so [ __ ] good for me so
we had that happen but maybe the biggest
story at a whole age though is kind of
The Return of the King because they
played the ready player one trailer and
Steven Spielberg showed up was just like
hey everybody remember this zip [ __ ]
you're superheroes oh my god this
trailer is [ __ ] glorious it's a mark
described in thusly what'd you say I was
like what how do you say it was like
Spielberg getting to play in Lego verse
it's like there's the [ __ ] Iron Giant
in there and there's a DeLorean car
chase like how did that happen because
you're Steven Spielberg you're like I
want everything I'm 75 years old and
[ __ ] it give it to me is he 75 yeah he's
up there are you [ __ ] me [ __ ] - man
I watched that trailer and I was like
this looks like it was made by some
young buck with vision [ __ ] 75 man
he's like look kid I'm looking backwards
at this point so much so that you at 46
are a kid that movie looks like it was
made by somebody who's at the top of
their [ __ ] game the prime of their
life and I'm certainly not saying like
all I've [ __ ] discounted Spielberg
ever but he's been lately doing
historical dramas yeah and I came weird
[ __ ] kids movies and nobody wants yes
like he seems he seems to be in his tusk
phase where you know
he just wants to do the [ __ ] he wants to
do and he's like if they come along
great if not a man I'm having a good
time and then remembered like oh [ __ ]
people pay money for this [ __ ] and then
suddenly came back with a movie that is
incredible like it that that won my
heart instantly and yes of course it
there's elements of like look it's the
[ __ ] Iron Giant look it's the [ __ ]
DeLorean yes he's playing with IP and
that's and that seems delicious and we
know if you know Ernest Cline's book how
deep that goes and if you're a guy whose
name is in Ernest Cline's book you're
sitting there going I hope they [ __ ]
keep that in there you know but it looks
glorious man it looks like it was made
by somebody who's like I have something
to prove and that man has nothing to
prove but he's come back to reclaim his
throne it wasn't it's a it's coming out
2018 [ __ ] that's too far away man I'm
sorry everything's 2018 I'm sorry um you
know what we don't right the [ __ ] into
it without even any four plates like we
went right for the clip hey everybody
sorry man we didn't even ease into that
conversation that whatsoever
but that was just right at the top of my
head because it's in the bud I felt like
a 10 how's your comic-con I'm good I
feel like you need to disclose something
[ __ ] I picked a blows away before I left
before I left LA to come down here I got
a I got a box I got a loot crate box as
one does when you actually pay for that
[ __ ] and inside this box was a pair of
underwear and on this underwear is your
face yeah I'm just trying to get close
to your dick as I can I mean and right
now you are because I'm wearing your
[ __ ] underwear tonight that
friendship ladies and gentlemen what's
amazing is you now have the ability to
like control my body and [ __ ] like that
so if you put your dick right against
the picture of Silent Bob and [ __ ] and
you get a boner you'll make me fit
what you do with the boner after that's
up to you
weekend at Bernie's that's yeah they did
a Jay and Bob underwear for Luke crepe
man they sent me a pair and I honestly I
would wear them I am the creep it's like
I'm on my own underwear and [ __ ] like
that
but they sent a bear that was like I
could get a leg into this and if I put
anything more my wife's going to be like
I'm leaving you seeing me poured into
that our past what is what you've been
doing all throughout comic-con gee do
any panels I did a couple panels to do
like an image comics panel how was that
they're celebrating 25 years everybody's
got 20 clawed [ __ ] like it is
Comic Con and though it was our comic
books yeah I did I did two comic book
panels both in support of this book that
I wrote called genius for Top Cow Oh
guys are adorable and then I marks
families here ladies and gentlemen
[Laughter]
and then I moderated the Lucifer panel
today oh [ __ ] are you a fan do you watch
I am I'm not nan fan but I've never
watched the show I am a fan I read we've
never really talked about it's not a
secret though I feel like I have many
interests like there's lots of other
things we've never talked about but we
won't also but yeah like one of others
asked me to do it and I walk the show
and I'm a fan and why the [ __ ] not
standing front of 2,000 people and ask
dumb questions to TV stars if you could
be any demon what demon would you be
I get paid for this [ __ ] I have been on
the IMD boat I'm Bodhi has a boat that
they brought down for the second year
and we've done interviews there but
interviewing people for I am to be did
it Sundance as well they don't let me
make anything anymore the way you talk
to the talented people and so that's
what I do so on the boat man I get to
see everybody that comes through and
then a lot of people that are doing
interview [ __ ] grinds inside like to
actually get out and get some fresh air
and stuff so did that Thursday Friday
and then Saturday and mostly it's like
you're shooting pieces and then they're
editing them real fast and then they
throw them right up on the IMDB but
Saturday was a live show today whoo and
so yeah it was fun it was just like it
we got everyone there's electricity in
the air they're live-streaming and on
lines on Twitch and on Twitter as well I
think there's a couple million people
streaming this this thing and now they
you know sold advertising so you got to
keep it on a clock and you felt like
doing a live show felt like doing a live
TV program and stuff and had all the
trappings of it and stuff the production
value look fantastic so you know we're
doing the live show and there's a series
of people coming on and there's no
breaks between each sometimes you can
run a clip package or something like
that
but generally speaking they're coming
through one of the first people we spoke
to liam Cunningham who plays tonight The
Onion Knight sir Davos and Game of
Thrones
he was absolutely [ __ ] lovely and then
after we chatted for like 12 minutes I
through to a clip package and then he
[ __ ] off and they brought in more
people and said and I talked them they
[ __ ] off so forth and so on
so two people that came in during the
live show Peter Capaldi Doctor Who and
salut yeah and
Steven Moffat so Steven of course been
on the show for a while I didn't
Sherlock he's off to do a Dracula not
like this minute that's not why he left
Doctor Who but like that's where he's
headed next but he's been with who've
quite
sometime and so you know during my intro
I was like hey welcome back to the IMD
boat look part of the fun of this job is
getting to meet the people to make the
stuff that you love stuff that moves you
and be able to tell them how much you
love their work man
they here to people I could barely just
spit it out now so excited to give it up
for Peter Capaldi and Steven Moffat the
who boys and stuff and everyone's
applauding so and so right away I launch
into you know the only way I know how to
do that job interview people is just
like here's my story now you tell me
yours and my story is usually about how
they've affected me or what they've done
that's wonderful or something so I
launched right in nothing prepared just
like launch right in and I'm like one of
my favorite piece hours of television
program ever produced is an episode of
Doctor Who called school reunion where
Sarah Jane Smith comes back and it said
it is the school k9 comes back I was
like it's such a beautiful piece of
programming from top to bottom
Isaac's I've watched it so many times
sometimes it just get blazed and watch
it over and over again I was like it is
it was just such a perfect one-hour
piece of programming them and Steven
Moffat goes thank you very much but
neither of us had anything to do with
that episode and we were alive and I was
like oh [ __ ]
and I knew of course Peter had nothing
to do with it but I thought Stephen was
on at that point but he's like now that
was right before me he's like then I
came out of the show he's going but it
felt good to hear you how much you loved
somebody else's work you know that was a
pity [ __ ] comment right there oh my good
lord but that was really my only kind of
misstep the one that when you're talking
to as many people as you're talking to
as fast as you're doing and stuff you
know you hope that you don't [ __ ]
step in [ __ ] by just saying something
like oh my god I hated that [ __ ]
movie you made one so much God you know
instead you just try to approach it with
real and honest and wound up that was
the one speed bump I hit where I was
like [ __ ] man if I just spent the time
looking up the information if I just
gone to oh I don't know the [ __ ] IMDB
but it spared myself better humiliation
and embarrassment stuff but it was a it
was also great i don't--all thing was
fun and i good time doing it I got to
see Stanley again it's no Comic Con
without seeing Stanley I'd seen Stan
earlier in the week he got his hands and
feet in the cement at the TCL the
Chinese theatres so I am seeing the
event and introduced yeah it was a
really [ __ ] cool moment especially
when you look down at the ground at the
people who have footprints there it's
not like you know other Creators it's
not like George Lucas Steven Spielberg
its actors and then there's [ __ ] fake
people like r2d2 and [ __ ] like that so
why not bring somebody who is yes he's
been in movies and stuff but more as a
cameo goof but this is a guy who's like
responsible for not just movies but a
lot of different entertainment man
starting careers based on [ __ ] that he
wrote 50 60 70 years ago so it seemed
like you know one moment of like how
justice is being done outside of the
pages of a comic book he deserves to be
here you know and so I got to get up and
speak at MC and introduce other people
and I was like you know hey man from New
Jersey and when we put people in cement
there's old everything I like hooray for
Hollywood we're here and said I got to
introduce Kevin Feige and then I get to
introduce he was the mastermind of the
Marvel Universe then I got to introduce
Clark Gregg Agent Coulson himself then I
got to introduce the Black Panther
himself Chadwick Chadwick Boseman
who gave a lovely [ __ ] like you know
we all got up there and really really I
love you Stan and he said something that
was really good like we were like holy
[ __ ] like I wish I'd been that relevant
ever but uh and then the last person I
introduced was Todd McFarlane who then
introduced Stan Stan got up there and
spoke and then like signed into cement
and stuff it was really cool to see the
whole thing go on but I had it since I
was in the room with these cats before
when I thought it afforded me a moment
to like lean into my fandom and anybody
listens this show and mark is one of
them because he's on it all the time you
know how much like I love those Marvel
movies and I don't say that [ __ ] some
people like you try to get a job like no
not at all like unless they're like you
know hey man
soare needs help from Jay and Silent Bob
you know like suit up Jay it's our time
but you can you can do something and not
have to do something that you love how
to explain that better like because of
what I do for a living I get a lot of
access to things that I wouldn't
necessarily get access to otherwise case
in point at one point now when a baby
was born
oh and she's now 18 so we're going back
18 years me and my wife would hardcore
mainline law-and-order
that TV show not the first one classic
none of this [ __ ] like Brick Squad
[ __ ] was horrifying you know like just
talking about the good old like we
killed people or did we you know and
[ __ ] hang him high McCoy brings him
to justice and all that [ __ ] so it was
great the kid used to love it like my
kid grew up to it when she was a infant
still like when she wasn't moving around
when she was doing the cross she could
sit back and when law and order would
begin and has that team boom boom
Denton's and no matter what the kid was
doing in the house she was so
conditioned because she watched the show
she watching we watched it and ignored
her and she had heard the music and knew
how to Pavlovian response to it after so
many times that would start and no
matter what she was doing she stopped
calling she'd stop sit back on her ass
and bounce in music so it's a good tune
bum bum bum bum bum and the kid would go
like this and I was always telling my
wife I was like I think we gave birth to
a stripper look at her
but keep her off the pole so I loved law
and order in a big bad way and I called
my agent one day and I was like in love
law and order man can I be on long long
order like there any way you could hook
this up do you know somebody's like I
know everybody and I was like all right
so can I be on it goes yeah [ __ ] yeah
you want to play like a guest sir and I
was like no [ __ ] that that's too much
pressure I'm not a good actor I just
want to be like the guy that leads them
to the guy that leads them to the guy
like one link in the chain I picked that
be cool they shoot New York I live in
New Jersey and he goes let me ask he
called back five minutes later he goes
they think it'd be funny to see Silent
Bob say things and I was like that's all
it took and he's like yeah you're a joke
and I was like fantastic and so so I got
to go do an episode of Law & Order I
worked Jesse Martin years before I
worked with him on flash I worked them
there he was ed green and and well
what's the great Jerry Orbach who played
what was it Lennie Briscoe well done and
that's why we know we love each other so
so it was fantastic fun to do but I
don't do that for everything in life
I don't sit there and watch those Marvel
movies and go call my agent Billy get me
one of those number one they'd be like
yeah right goodbye
and I got you more importantly like I
can appreciate you without wanting to do
it without wanting to play with the toys
and stuff some [ __ ] is just nice to look
at like I'm a fat guy but I don't buy
every piece of food when I go into the
food store sometimes I just look at you
and be like one day you know or more
like that's too good for even me you
know if I can move on so I could go see
a movie and just [ __ ] enjoy it and
not be like wow does what does this mean
to me and how does it fit into my career
because I to make movies and [ __ ]
because let's be honest those are movies
that I make movies so there's no real
comparison anyway so I love those flicks
like and people say I'm in the bag from
absolutely I just love that they come to
life because they are the closest thing
to a fountain of youth I've ever felt I
watch those movies and I feel the way I
felt when I was a kid watching Star Wars
or watching Raiders of the Lost Ark the
same sort of like oh my god you took me
somewhere and it's a bigger deal at my
age now because I'm [ __ ] 40
I should be more concerned about like
I'm going to die I got hemorrhoids
whatever to fox-like but instead like I
can still settle back into a movie
theater for two hours they'll take me
someplace that reminds me how I felt
when I would watch movies as a kid long
before I ever thought about getting old
just at the days of like pain man I want
to skate take me to a different world so
I loved those movies like i rewatch them
all the time they're my go-to happy
place so you know we're sitting there in
Marvel Central Kevin Feige he's there
and I never see this guy and I talk
about him all the [ __ ] time and in a
good way I'm always going like this
guy's a punk a genius and [ __ ] like that
and so people like you're trying to get
a job I'm like no I'm just communicating
that I think he's great [ __ ]
storytellers have these phases of the
Marvel Universe planned out and he's
retrained he's or rather retrain he's
trained people who weren't trained like
me at a young age going like okay this
adventure is over I have to wait a month
to go to this adventure or I could go
over to this issue and follow the story
with other characters and [ __ ] like that
they do that to my mom now where my
mom's like Oh tiger did you know that
Ant Man and the wasp is coming soon and
I'm like how the [ __ ] do you know that
and you know she's like I stay after the
credits you know and stuff like that so
they've trained a nation of people to
consume movies the way I was trained to
consume comic books like yes dispenses
adventures amazing and satisfying but
guess what man stick around there's
going to be more and stuff so they make
me feel young again when I go to those
movies I see this guy he he turns around
and he goes and I even know if he
remembered me and he goes Oh Kevin long
time no see and rather than just be like
hey Kevin oh my god like boy you're
kicking ass over at marvel studios I
just [ __ ] hugged him dude as hard as
I could my face on his chest like I
can't quit you he like [ __ ] really
deal and then I held it uncomfortably
long
like for a long did you drop a hand no
but he started moving his hand like kids
at first he was like haha like that like
oh that's a sweet thing but then it
turned to like haha cuz I'm not hold on
and finally he had to give me the Pat
like this as if he was my wife and I'm
eating [ __ ] just like you're done
killer you're done and I let go and I
was like oh my god dude I just you're my
favorite storyteller working right now
thinking about the other day like the
way you put all these movies together in
the way like I can fall down the rabbit
hole I just rewatched Iron Man recently
which then took me through the entire
Marvel Cinematic Universe again cuz I
was like oh yeah what happened next
oh yeah what happened next so anybody
that can make me feel that young at
heart and should knowing what I know and
knowing that I can see the strings and
know how that [ __ ] is done I take my ID
take my shirt off for him but a
terrifying but that's the highest honor
I could give somebody instead I give him
a big hug he was very sweet at first you
could tell he was like oh please don't
ask me for a job please don't ask me for
a job but he could tell that I care I
said dude you doing the Lord's work I
said when you get free time come over
and do an episode of fat man on Batman
and he looked a little relieved like I
wasn't asking for a job but I was asking
for something he's like I could do that
he was like I would love to so hopefully
we get Kevin Feige over I mean I'm going
to ask him for all the jobs is actually
didn't [ __ ] it by that's okay man I'll
just be the guy watching I would love to
watch your stuff I'd love it if they'd
hire you you're like one of the [ __ ]
smartest storytellers I know you could
break [ __ ] down in a really intelligent
way they'd be wise to pull you in that's
just me [ __ ] doing a piece
[Applause]
it's just like me and Kevin find it ah
okay no it's there's one more hug I
gotta tell you about ya there who
another how James Gunn was there James
Gunn I don't know why the [ __ ] he wasn't
speaking maybe he's feeling under the
weather or something like that but lord
if anybody should have been up there
talking about stand it should have been
him but he was there in the audience and
then right before he went out I saw him
and I tapped him he turned around and
goodnight and I [ __ ] went in and did
the uncomfortable hug and kept it and
stuff like that and he was more
receptive out he's like that's it so get
up there like take it all and so far I
got to break that hug and I said let me
tell you something
that movie is like definitely my
favorite movie of the summer and it may
wind up still being my favorite movie of
the year I said I sit around in my car
and I listened to that soundtrack over
and over for volume two and it reminds
me of wonderful scenes in the movie that
I fell in love with in the theater so
much so that I went to see it three
times you know many things I go see in
the theater three times I don't even go
see [ __ ] yoga hosers in the theater
three times I feel like that
so on he was like oh my god thank you
and then I went onstage into the rest of
it [ __ ] and then we after it was done we
were all going back in and James coming
in again so I was like so anyway man I
[ __ ] loved win and I went right back
into the conversation and got to talk
about specific moments that I loved and
that's what I love about doing what I do
the byproducts like you know I know some
people got into the media game or a
filmmaking game and they like different
byproducts some people like the parties
and [ __ ] like that like I love the
lifestyle and [ __ ] like that I love that
it's given me acts like megan clerks all
these years later has given me access to
the point where i can tell somebody
whose work means so they rather than
just do it on social media and hope they
read it face to face so they can see the
profundity of the statement and be like
I [ __ ] love what you do it is pure
[ __ ] magic man like that's the joy of
being me not that like I get to make
goofy movies nobody likes it's more that
I get to [ __ ] meet people that I love
and say that I don't have to carry that
around and [ __ ] and I don't have to
write it and throw it in the ether and
you know what happens if I were to just
write that online and post it to
somebody then I'm getting into an
argument with a bunch of [ __ ]
who were just like you're wrong you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] your heart
eat it you know and [ __ ] like that
you're just like Hitler and so it it's
nice to be able to see these people in
person and have that kind of moment
that's what Comic Con I guess is kind of
all about two things yes I would not
discount the joys of watching ice-t
wrestle with sex crimes so like he
sniffs painting yes
I stink he's missed a bike he gets off
on it yes I see it like that's all that
[ __ ] show is it's like ice-t coming
to gritties with awful [ __ ] I can't
believe you held on to that that long
you're like yeah I can't wait till he
shuts up I'm gonna talk about how
[ __ ] good ideas on that show you just
wait you [ __ ] you can staring
it by Stieg on I'll remember I'll
remember and and like comic-con for me
this is my 16th comic-con in a row yeah
I know like my comic-con attendants can
now drive and like every time I come my
brain is like hey you're still 28 right
you can absolutely do this like a 28
year old and by Friday my body's like
[ __ ] you know by Saturday like my knees
are powdering my spine is fused and I'm
like hobbling from place to place and
yet I still feel young as when the world
was new it is well the problem is you
[ __ ] mix booze into comic-con man I
met I was I'm joking I see I've mixed
weeded to it believe me that's the only
way to survive it and sure like that but
booze
takes a lot out of them we on the boat
I'm the name drop again on the boat
today the folks from Rick and Morty so a
Justin was there and Dan Harmon was
there and so Dan Harmon at one point
like in some pretty cheery person and
stuff and you know he's [ __ ] studying
me and and he goes he's listened to
everything I say and he's just like why
he's gone but you don't you're not
bitter or anything like that or he's
asking a question I wasn't no no and
then at one point I said something about
weed and he goes yeah but do you drink
and I said no I just smell
he goes oh that's what makes sense I
said wine he goes let's try to figure
out why there's we're the same age but
my beard is gray and yours is not he's
like it's the booze is the difference
and I was like oh I guess I hadn't
thought about it I got to [ __ ] fan out
on those cats as well and just talk
about like [ __ ] deep cuts moments and
stuff oh it's [ __ ] beautiful you know
it was even nicer sometimes you tell
people like your favorite moment of
something they've done and you trip
their wire where they're like that is
actually one of my favorite moments and
they tell you more [ __ ] information
this is if you've ever watched Rick and
Morty remember the unity episode for
those that don't follow it it's a genius
show give it a shot and stuff
smartest [ __ ] humour you'll see kind
of on display right now and at one point
he talked about it's not you know for me
I'm like what do you guys just sit
around make jokes and he goes yeah we
definitely do that but we also break it
down in a Joseph Campbell type way he's
like what is the characters heroic
journey is like of every episode though
again I was like that's what makes [ __ ]
good you guys put thought into it what
not that's the missing ingredient stuff
so in the in this one episode Rick of
Rick and Morty Fame he runs into an old
flame who is essentially a Borg you know
assimilated Borg essentially unity is a
bunch of people there's one identity
consumed by a bunch of people so she can
change personalities and human bodies in
dealing with them and it basically
becomes like a [ __ ] fest for the whole
episode and [ __ ] like that because she
could be anybody and everybody so he
could [ __ ] twenty people and it's still
unity and stuff they take science tropes
and they really [ __ ] science fiction
tropes and really [ __ ] them but at
the end of it like it wouldn't work
anymore and her friends were keeping him
away from her it's just like you're not
good for unity and stuff just like he's
a bad boyfriend because they had really
great sex but everything else was
terrible and so so at the very tail end
of the episode he's talking to spending
like what about unities like I we
shouldn't be together and stuff some
people aren't meant to be or something
like that it goes out into the garage
and [ __ ] they play this really
[ __ ] like sad depressing song [ __ ]
which is a great song too but it's
really [ __ ] somber
and he creates a form of life pulls out
some protoplasm put some juice on and
creates life this thing comes to life
and as you're watching it gone like
what's going on like is he trying to
build a friend what's going what's the
stirrer
then he builds another piece of
equipment and [ __ ] and puts the thing
right under it and pulls a lever and it
destroys it it [ __ ] incinerates it
and then he changes the bowl and puts
then and he's about to incinerate
himself the same way he's tried it out
he created life is just so desperate to
feel something he created life and then
destroyed it right in front of himself
and now he's going to [ __ ] take his
own life and just before the [ __ ]
laser goes off he's drunk so he passes
out and it misses him in [ __ ] and then
he lays there on the desk and in the
garage they pull out wide and then you
see like his son-in-law later in the day
just kind of weed whacking on the lawn
and [ __ ] like nothing major just almost
happened in the other room is [ __ ]
profound it's a very funny show I'm not
doing it just as obviously but it's a
really deep moment in a very [ __ ]
funny show so I was talking about that
and he goes who he goes that he's gone I
love that scene he's going what I always
saw that scene what make because I was
like that's dark dude that's like some
of the darkest [ __ ] I've ever [ __ ]
seen in my life he goes what makes it
even darker he's gone when we came up
with it he's gone that thing that he
created and then destroyed he was
destroyed it's [ __ ] up he was
destroying across every dimension that
ever existed so he wasn't just killing
it there because I'm Rick and Morty they
could pop two different dimensions he
was destroying it throughout the
universe and so then he was trying to do
that to himself but failed because he
was miserably drunk and he was like
that's one of my favorite things and I'm
like oh my god man that is so [ __ ]
metal
being able to talk to the creator and
find out little tidbits like that like
[ __ ] in a fair world that would get
me laid by my wife and well I walk by
the boat today and I saw you talking to
mike colter yes I hate that [ __ ] dude
because he's not fair you should not be
that handsome and also funny can I add
something to the load what eloquent he's
a fantastic [ __ ] chatter offense like I
got to walk around like this yeah for
the rest of my life and he's that yeah
just making people pregnant in rooms we
walked through no [ __ ] that guy welcome
to my world you got one guy you're
worried about everybody's a [ __ ]
improvement over me and should he he was
on the boat as well and [ __ ] if he
wasn't efficient eloquent and [ __ ] uh
he'd give you just enough information
he's like well-heeled
at the [ __ ] interview now well school
maybe just [ __ ] train himself I
interviewed him a year ago for geeking
out and he was okay or actually he was
with somebody so maybe he's sharing the
spotlight I'm telling you dude who sat
down today was just like bam bam bam he
knew how to give you [ __ ] all the
answers you wanted more than the things
you were looking for content that was
all like [ __ ] that's a sound bite right
there and stuff it was it for a guy who
talks for a living and tries to get
other people to talk you appreciate
people that can succinctly make a point
or make a point at all you know some
people you talk to you know like how do
you feel about that they're like good
you know and there's nothing there and
you got okay on to the next thing he
asked Mike a question he can deep dive
for minimum two minutes man you can
catch your breath and then go into the
next question and easiest [ __ ] to look
at last year when I was here I was
working for the only times and he came
into the video sweet for the times just
[ __ ] swanned in like Luke aids and
there's a woman like nine months
pregnant like checking people in and he
walks over like lays a hand on her belly
it's like putting like eight and a half
months and she almost took her shirt off
she was there like let's do this right
now
this is
room for two come on isn't sweet
Christmas speaking of which I the
defenders I've seen the first three
episodes in have you real I have holy
[ __ ] alright I know they had the panel
yesterday in all ages ago the they
showed number one they showed the one
episode they weren't even supposed to
but they're like why me maybe they were
planning it but they were like we're
going to show you the whole episode and
the reaction on Twitter was massive
people seem to dig it you've seen three
episodes I've seen derivatives seventy
five percent of that show is awesome
Jeana you know the one part that's not
awesome Sigourney Weaver no her
pantsuits are amazing but I know it's
every time the story centered like
swerves away from over the lawyers who's
fighting his hidden past and doesn't
want to give in to his violent urges and
the drunk private investigator who's
trying to pull a life back together in
the ex-convict who gets out of jail and
just wants to get coffee with Claire and
that happens it's like as soon as he
goes off the [ __ ] bus but then
there's this other guy and the rest and
every time that other dude shows up
you're like I don't want any of this
with you you made it through all of Iron
Fist inning I did I did - it took some
doing yeah it took a minute it took a
minute I wasn't like by the end of it I
wasn't as some people like come on hey
man we got an iron fist we're on our way
we're one step closer to the defenders
and there's some cool [ __ ] there Colleen
wing was really [ __ ] cool seeing
Claire get a lot more screen time was
really cool and I because they're open
I'm not supposed to spoil anything to
the embargoes like the 24th of July but
that's what like Monday yeah you're good
so [ __ ] it we're fine yeah and I'm not
gonna go jeez because you don't want to
eat their arse ever does these are just
the tip cutting I love I'm surface area
I'm not digging tunnels I'm just but
there's a scene at the end of episode 2
where it gave me a thing I didn't know I
wanted as bad as I wanted it when Luke
Cage beats the [ __ ] out of iron
oh really yeah it's kind of awesome my
first my you know instantly I want to be
like why they're supposed to be friends
but I'm sure maybe nobody starts his
friends oh really
number that time we beat the [ __ ] out of
each other and be true friends as how we
became bread [ __ ] around then we were
like let's defend people and then and
then at the end of episode 3 you get and
you've seen the scene in the trailers
we're all for them are fighting together
yeah and that's [ __ ] transcendent but
you got to endure a decent amount of
iron fist to get there I'm just saying
you're getting iron fisted before the
good stuff what hours you go any Weaver
and who is she anybody from Marvel
Comics or no not that I can tell so far
but she's you know ominous man she's
like evil Hillary Clinton were they
making this at the hoping for different
results or something or no I mean it
would have been helpful right for
Humanity hub is she in control of like
the Hannah's handbag do you want to know
well I mean they saw the trailer and
electors in it so I had to assume the
hand plays a part it does indeed and
stick shows up those stick is in the
Joey better show up yeah he was in the
[ __ ] teasers are you guys are [ __ ]
god abused you go teach in New York be
super friend of you there's a line in
the trailer where he's like I don't want
any super friends or something like that
is that did you see that part I had now
that my second I was in the trailer made
me left it was a Luke Cage like I'm not
looking for any Super Friends there it
is a decent amount of girl lap right
there man but there's a decent amount of
everybody like not understanding and
calling [ __ ] on like I'm the
immortal iron fist like what the [ __ ] is
that I'm a guard in the Kunlun [ __ ]
it's all of that it's kind of great that
sounds a lot like Jessica Jones doing a
lot of yeah everybody does it because
it's a dumbest [ __ ] idea of it nom I
channeled my Chi and and one part of my
body glows and I punched through things
with it not everything because again you
could iron fists all the time if you
have total control of your Chi just
[ __ ] everything gets iron fisted
but no when I gotta me cominius does he
need he needs time to recharge on the TV
show he did right because I remember at
one point that's what he needs to do is
like this is how I recharge Oh give you
like 20 minutes why do you take my piss
mate iron I cannot think um all right
which should we talk about the we talk
about the [ __ ] we see this should be
then Malaysia we haven't signed the news
that broke alright break some new doctor
news abroad we got a list of thing
there's a list of things ah
so Ben Affleck who is apparently still
Batman for now might not be Batman for
long you basing this on a Hollywood
Reporter article that ran yesterday yeah
I think it was Friday speculating that
Affleck was this Justice League was the
last time that you'd see Ben play Batman
right and what he's happy about
somebody's unhappy it's it's there was a
it seemed come out of well no no not
know where he did back away from
directing it and they have since changed
course with the script and I'm using
script I mean we talked about that when
that means first broke like if he's not
directing the Batman I don't think he
stars in the Batman is if you've got to
build a bat universe around a dude you
know willing to be fifty years old as
Batman it seemed like and we I think we
had talked about the time like all right
slow exit you know like they're not
they're like don't quit the movie you
know directing it and and acting in a
G's let's do this in pieces so suddenly
it felt like oh yeah I guess this is the
last piece I mean weird timing because
like he's got to come here and sell
Justice League at comic-con then cut to
today where he comes out on stage for
the Hall H presentation and kind of
turns the story around says something
the honor of the quotes but something
effective like that Batman is the
greatest character I think he curves
[ __ ] character on the planet and I
love playing him or something like that
the thing is whatever he said I read it
and it didn't
Sara Lee dispute the hollow reporter
article he didn't say I'm not going
anywhere you know it's just like I love
Batman to a roomful of people like yeah
I farted in this suit to suit his mind I
don't even say that
I'm wondering if you know it was an it
felt like a non-denial denial you know
what I'm saying and then I read it wrong
did you rape people right I mean and and
I also wonder leave a gap on the quote
you tell you look at it this is how this
works and also I'm wondering if because
they also talked about like finding a
graceful exit for Ben as as Bruce Wayne
right now do you think and do you want
them to kill Bruce Wayne no because
they're gonna kill a Captain America
what I mean guys come on now they're
killing Captain America I absolutely
have a hard-on for the shot of Captain
America dead on the on the steps of the
whatever the [ __ ] Capitol building
are you is that a fan theory I mean
that's what happened in the Winter
Soldier books and they're all about that
they are absolutely letting towards the
place where you know cap will go rogue
he will come back in he will be the hero
once again and that is when you kill
America's greatest hit soldier who kills
them Thanos to the continued Colin I
mean it had been look out [ __ ] I'm on
the edge of my seat you don't even know
I'm making this [ __ ] up like cool what
could it be I don't know the closure
goes I really like here take my money we
buy our tickets fast to this movie that
doesn't exist I mean if I'm making this
movie Black Widow kills them oh you
[ __ ] cold what but Wow
at Thanos controls or danos there's
something huge has to kill [ __ ] Steve
that's not of this earth and it should
be him and we watch the fight I hate
getting in these conversations because
it's like all this shit's made up but we
watched them him fight Iron Man and
stuff like it no mortal was going to
take down Captain America it's going to
take a mad Titan from space or is going
to take somebody he trusts implicit
oh [ __ ] you're smart dude goddammit
that's [ __ ] smart man but I also like
the Batman is bigger than any one actor
yes you know and there's no real and
[ __ ] we had an in continuity Batman
change and nobody gave a [ __ ] where like
Michael golf is still Alfred but
suddenly it's Clooney and then suddenly
it's Kilmer or vice versa cuz I forget
when that happens but we don't care
ultimately it's Batman I want to see
hold on here's the quote ready coming
from Ben Affleck himself clearing rumors
slash current stories quote I am the
Batman I have the coolest job ever
unquote I mean is he like eight but I
say when I say Who I mean it's really
just a kind of it sounds like a humble
brag I am the Batman I have the coolest
job ever
I am those are present tense I am the
Batman for my whole today I have the
coolest job ever until I walk away from
this [ __ ] you know what I'm saying he's
still covered and remember there it
wasn't long ago I think it was last year
they were like they're gonna he's going
to direct the Batman movie and then a
couple months later like he's not
restoration so I don't know what do you
think many tickets for reals you think
he's doing it I mean I think it's for
real I think if they're going to
continue especially if you're using
quotes oh thank you thanks to [ __ ]
Twitter we can listen to Ben Affleck's
own words here we go
[Applause]
I'm so thrilled to do that adrenaline is
[ __ ] amazing and three three on
tokens Jarrah scroll I don't never
descent mean really you know I believe
in true memories doing it like I feel
that about you what I'm really blown
away excited and a great time in the DC
Universe from just reading
I mean honestly like that's that's not
like I'm [ __ ] locked and loaded
they're gonna have to pull my [ __ ]
dead ass out of the Batcave on my hands
are on my bat-pole from now until the
end of time there's a guy going like hey
man shit's nice now sure is nice to be
here you know I don't know if there's I
don't know we'll see that's already Ross
is building a bat universe around that
girl and you can have the Gotham City
sirens and you're going to lean into all
this
yes I think you start over I think you
start clean you start fresh you make a
whole new [ __ ] thing this I mean do
they even have to do anything like me
just check if you're gonna change Batman
change Batman it just keep moving
forward you like it bond can do it then
that make it and then make a joke about
it two stories down the line about like
you know how remember Martha shut the
[ __ ] up and move on what what else what
else is in the news
well DC also named a bunch of movies in
there extend the universe they gave some
some titles to what's happening for sure
really yes okay I'm going to read
Suzette's core - we knew the Batman we
knew Shazam just as lamp
Shazam that happened I mean we got it
there was a bunch of stories that ran I
think on Thursday Friday Thursday my
thing
we had a Annabel creation on the boat
the director that is David Sandberg and
like right before the interview with
them like somebody was like I hear he
might be making
em one day another god I'd be [ __ ]
funny so I uh
during that interview I go hey uh watch
what do you what's down the road for you
man like you can jump into the world of
crazy superheroes or something like that
and he goes at my next movie of Shazam
it's like with no irony whatsoever no
build-up no showmanship like get ready
for this Batman get ready it [ __ ] shows
I'm or something like that literally
just like and I was like are you [ __ ]
serious he goes yes yes I am serious I
was like what you're just gonna say it
like that like I thought you danced
around it I had no idea just so how'd
you get that you know suddenly I was
falling down a different rabbit hole
people seemed so happy to be in the DC
Universe big bad way Shazam um what do
you think I can't call him Captain
Marvel that's his real name
you're right his ever calm got Marvel in
the movie I mean they should just
[ __ ] make the blackout a movie and
move on because that's all anybody
really wants is the rock as black Adam
and I think I saw something on Twitter I
don't know if it's confirmed but Jeff
Jeff Jon says that that the rock is not
going to be in the Shazam movie again we
can look it up into it but that's what I
read earlier today because I - mom they
asked they said Shazam I think if you
have an interview it's like all mine the
rock is blowing and it's not like the
director was like haha you didn't really
say anything so maybe they're like Jeff
is you know going hey before everyone
gets excited we're making Shazam not
black Adam but you're absolutely right
everyone wants us yeah so Justice League
dark apparently they're still trying to
make why not just look instead of
waiting what why has he got a black Adam
why can't he be [ __ ] cat Marvel why
can't he be Shazam he could be I mean
[ __ ] I'd do it make him she said I
wouldn't be she's env2 I was like nobody
wants nobody wants had a I'm a
middle-aged man
I love comic books but and then I'm a
little white kid this is weird
that'll be an interesting movie wouldn't
though yeah the Wizards give a little
white kid power to turn into you you
want to also not be able to catch a cab
come on kid give it a you can solve that
problem I can't catch a cab Shazam and
you a little white kid and happy and
they poke I know money is a little white
dude oh [ __ ] you're right
well when they stop and [ __ ] and you're
like Shazam and you jump in the cab real
quick like tiny and privilege giant and
target that's the way you down for a
movie how do you feel as the comp
appears I did see some people on Twitter
grousing about you know come on man if
it aint captain if you can't call a cat
Marvel Inc at Marvel they can't call
Captain Marvel because Marvel has a
character called Captain Marvel who
showed up today we'll get to that in a
minute
but uh but you can't do with the DC
movie under the proper term I feel like
they're giving us DC movies just to give
us DC movies oh hey come on don't give
us I'll take them but like issues like I
think they're given us blow jobs just to
give us blow jobs like I will take all
the blow job
[Laughter]
I'm sure like that's stood there from
just hang in the air what else did they
what else did they announce Justice
League dark witch wait so that's going
to be a feature no did they even
announce a director just a title just a
title
closely Guillermo righty what it was but
not no longer no he's never doing it no
really why I think that he wanted to
make an actual movie haha oh you big bad
girl which we knew about so it didn't
just Batgirl just a girl they give it a
title or anything this is this flat out
back from time I they bring out anybody
like Whedon with their yeah we'd miss
Dylan London shooting a reshooting it's
a Justice League is here the [ __ ] he
shooting you sitting around go where's
everybody
this is a dark sky should ring of trash
over London Green Lantern Corps they've
told us about that they tell us about
that you know it's exciting though in
the Justice League trailer which is
[ __ ] eye candy galore and should they
reference yeah Lance spoilers don't [ __ ]
it you're spoiled they reference
lanterns at one point they're like you
hear the voice of what I'm assuming is
Steppenwolf going this this planet or
whatever this world has no Kryptonians
no lanterns and I've got [ __ ] so
excited like Olli [ __ ] they're finally
talking about lanterns without Ryan
Reynolds involved this is going to be
[ __ ] amazing what do you think it's
going to be well I think they talk a lot
about it being like the gut buddy cop
show where well do you think we'll get a
taste in justice league if they were
smart they would you know what I'm
saying yes there's a land of it but
you're in Leiter's [ __ ] the ring
pulling up they just held his hand like
just do that that's [ __ ] yeah you do the
the death of a Bandhan sir right and
then [ __ ] the ring falling on you
then you don't even have to cast it you
just put the ring on somebody's hand and
then credit and in fact the credits have
already happened let's be honest this is
after the [ __ ] credits you know
that's genius them sometimes they get
sad because we're not in charge
I get so wrapped up I'm like let's do
that and I'm like we have no power the
flash flash point so they're saying that
they're doing a flash and they're given
a subtitle flash point which it's not
like we already saw that on a TV show
that lots of people watch every week
look I love that TV show and I've worked
on that TV show but be fair thank you
but to be fair they they you know they
did they did a variation of that story
throughout all of last season but if you
were like if you're telling me we're
going to do Geoff Johns flashpoint we're
going to do the flash point that you
watched the DC animated movie up it's
just going to have real people in it
this time then I'm definitely I'm on
board I think was worth doing yeah
that's a [ __ ] beautiful story man it
really is it anally well done and there
are a lot of moments that they couldn't
replicate possibly in the flash TV show
like [ __ ] think about flashpoint you
got all that beautiful Thomas Wayne
stuff if you've never followed the story
Barry Allen makes everything right saves
mom's life and makes everything right
and the trickle-down effect the
butterfly effect destroys the DC
Universe in ways that at first are minor
and then ways major and at one point
Barry meets the Batman from this
timeline but it's not Bruce Wayne it's
Thomas Wayne his father the boy the boy
is killed in the alleyway and the father
lives to grow up to become an Avenger
and he's a [ __ ] drinker and he curses
and [ __ ] like that and if you follow
that storyline deeper into the comics
the mother became the Joker it was
pretty [ __ ] genius and stuff I know
right doesn't make you want to read it
right now
you're not going to see that in a movie
theater minimum five ten years do
yourself a favor go pick up those books
and read them the old-fashioned way so
if they do that if they're doing
flashpoint where and you know the DC
Universe they do whatever the [ __ ] they
want on the big screen don't you know
they're going to do that variation of
Batman so it's definitely worth pursuing
plus like I love Tom Cavanagh but I'll
never get enough [ __ ] professor zoom
I'll never get enough backwards flash
eobard thawne so I'm ready to see that
on the big screen here's what I would
love I would love if Ben Affleck steps
away from the Batman but plays Thomas
Wayne yes
[ __ ] [ __ ] look let's make your movie
again man a good idea why don't they
have these meetings that [ __ ] Warner
Brothers and [ __ ] whether it seems like
they have meetings with like you think
everyone will be unhappy like yeah
alright let's we're done maybe not that
then alright what else let's jump into
that Justice League trailer real quick
features of it
moments open strong I thought smart too
you can tell the times we live in it
opens all Wonder Woman yes it does
totally so much so that if you're like
not somebody to follow [ __ ] this [ __ ]
closely a bit like oh they made a sequel
already that was [ __ ] fast you know I
know that thing everybody likes a lot
let's just do that
here's [ __ ] more of it so it starts
with her which is great not a little
button joke of her in the museum and
show the guy go would you do Diana she's
like [ __ ] up people not sure but and
then they jump into the credits and one
of the first images you see is they
acknowledge the world without a Superman
and they talk about Batman the Bat Man
or the back of Gotham whatever they're
calling them not being around and they
say something like crime has run rampant
in the world like world crime [ __ ] like
that or sometimes like ooh that sounds
metal and so then they start slowly
showing you like you know oh we saw one
piece before a Bruce Wayne talking to
Diana and stuff and her gone like I
thought the age of euros was dead he
says it has to come back or whatever and
then you see the team what's insanely
impressive in this trailer first one we
saw
looks like Aquaman is going to be a good
time this trailer looks like ho [ __ ]
this is the Aquaman movie like this is
[ __ ] he steals the show is an amazing
[ __ ] shot of him sliding down a
building and [ __ ] that's fantastic I
think they're leaning into surfer bro
Aquaman so hard and I loved every minute
of it
hey he's just like a better dig it yes
yes all of that all the time yeah yeah
and also very a very no more take on
Aquaman certainly not the Aquaman of our
childhood he talks too fishy like this
is a little bit like Oh God you with a
[ __ ] pitchfork you fool on Ocean
pitchfork also called the Trident yeah
man some wonderful stuff on display in
that trailer would you like in the
trailer I mean I I love Commissioner
Gordon
I just want grizzled angry Commissioner
Gordon all the time
I still don't know what the [ __ ] cyborg
is doing in this movie other than it was
like diversity hire but aren't I
supposed to say that [ __ ] I can get away
with it though man I got it Rebecca race
cards here whipping him around I don't
know I'll go the other way I actually
like his smooth calm performance when
he's like I'll take it from here Alfred
I'm kind of looking forward to because
the last time we saw the first time we
saw this kid was his birth in like the
Batman V Superman [ __ ] stroke videos
that he's watching at one point in that
movie where you see him come along he's
a guide in agony screaming so I like
that they portrayed them as pretty damn
calm not robotic but pretty damn kind of
down here everything's right here and
well that's what you have to do if
you're a black guy in a superhero movie
all right lay it down take it down hey
all right why do I got your [ __ ] damn
I'll be right here man it's all good you
don't have a fine as long as you move
and starring Lou Rawls
what what else what's next on the list
of news let's see it was a Marvel [ __ ]
got that Captain Marvel
that was huge man number one they showed
images of brie Larson in the costume
number two they showed the d23 footage
of infinity wars what are they calling
it yeah Avengers infinity war
this one's infinity war and the next one
is untitled Devin says okay so infinity
war footage that was shown at d23 but
apparently had one added piece that
wasn't a d23 because nobody was talking
about it on twitter they in that footage
the Avengers footage Captain Marvel was
there and that's nothing that I've heard
about was going to happen like which
they gave out another piece of
information which then makes you go what
the [ __ ] is going on when they do the
Captain Marvel movie it is set in the
90s and we're going to see Sam Jackson
as Nick Fury with two good eyes that's
what they announced today and you're
like wait how is this possible and then
the character is also going to be in
infinity woman this is everything we
learned today out of the panel and stuff
how do you think they're accomplishing
that got a [ __ ] with time somehow
right it's one of the gems a time gem or
something like that yes the Infinity gem
is another all infinite okay one of
them's a time Jim maybe that's the way
to do I think that's [ __ ] awesome
number one 90s costume that's fantastic
because everybody wants 90s costumes yes
and yet just Sam Jackson not having to
stumble awkwardly to the left yeah
what do you think they're gonna do I
mean because we've seen Sam Jackson like
fit over the last few Avengers films and
the only the only age in one direction
so this is a movie that's set in the 90s
is there any chance that it's not Sam
Jackson now like say always it's always
Sam and Martha pending a [ __ ] ton Jodi
age and they have they have now
pioneered the art of making old men look
halfway young it's true yeah but usually
for like 30 seconds in the movie if he's
a main character man that's a long time
that's a lot of shots I would like the
back of a bald head oh good point but
yeah better [ __ ] filmmaker than I am
man like I am sitting there going we got
to spend a lot of money or like no don't
shoot over here could he use you years
ago I'm fighting news that they're
putting Captain Marvel in the movie but
obviously look they've always been
talking about hey man Captain Marvel's
coming hey man captain Marvel's coming
but after the year of Wonder Woman like
hey man cap Marvel's here for real we
got ya oh here she is look at her than
awesome so there Marvel finally thrown
in with the lady then for any male lead
Michelle Pfeiffer is cast as Janet Van
Dyne a man man are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
me they announced that yeah that's
pretty damn awesome man and there's a
scene that they played in the panel
which I would give my eyeteeth to see of
Paul Rudd and Michael Pena explaining
the history of the MCU to Janet Van Dyne
that's in the that's bad that the
footage that they showed from from a man
and a wasp I even hear about this number
the time when like you know David they
fought the [ __ ] giant guy and the
airport that was cool right member that
a little tiny spot a guy food fun Queens
remember that guy that's what they were
doing a whole scene the whole scene of
that how long was it
mmm minutes is it meant to be a trailer
is it probably I guess from the flick so
are they're shooting on Ant Man in the
wasp ready yeah
are they done or they're like we're
having a live reduction wow man I had no
idea I didn't know that they were
showing that I thought like they've come
to comic-con and show the vengers
footage and everybody like thank you
coming without touching themselves and
[ __ ] but they they [ __ ] came overly
prepared overly packed once again it's
an example of [ __ ] like DC comes in
there like look at our Justice League
Weiner you know and everyone's like oh
that's [ __ ] impressive than Marvel's
like look at this [ __ ] monster open
the doors in the back here at Tom man
they [ __ ] brought like just an army
to a knife fight
so that's blank black panther footage
yeah
Avengers for Avengers footage teensy
Clipper Mad Men and so a new Thor
trailer and the new Thor trailer which
is fantastic and it teensy clips from
aunt Minn so that's four big things and
this is the end right like Avengers
infinity war represents the end of Phase
three right and so that the missile
kicks off phase four are you [ __ ] me
yeah so then after that the next
Avengers movie is phase four as well
they keep talents like don't expect
anything to be the same things and you
said that you think they're gonna kill
Captain America yeah that's your belief
that's my belief is it your hope I mean
as a storyteller
george'll yeah like that would be
satisfied that is that if Coulson's
death is the thing that initiates the
Avengers with Captain America's a
beating heart then his death would be
the perfect way to transition into a
completely different phase that's where
I go cuz I'm a heartless bastard good
writing man that's [ __ ] I really want
to watch your Avengers movies well next
time you hug a dude just drop a
brother's name yeah man
[Applause]
[Laughter]
tickling your lobe while you do it just
they get him [ __ ] off me man he's
[ __ ] whispered something in my ear
what he's I said Marc Bernardo what else
you got uh Fox is making a standalone
dr. doom film this is [ __ ] hot news
to me I think this is interesting I
think it's a good [ __ ] idea number
one we know they've had some trouble not
even true those the two fantastic four
movies they may is to write three well
not coming of that one series and then
just go rise of the Silver Surfer yeah
the two of those and then bit I like
those movies I know like they could do
something different [ __ ] but I liked
them for what they were Stanley is
Willie Lumpkin is a dream come true so I
like those movies for what they are
you know Josh Trank had a vision and
clearly it was not in sync with the rest
of the world and we know they rather
than go like [ __ ] we're going back to
the drawing board making another
Fantastic Four yeah they're like look we
got to hold onto the license we don't
make some movie of the Fantastic Four
universe we got to give all this [ __ ]
back to Marvel we got to do something
let's be smart about this instead of
doing the Fantastic Four again like how
about Doctor Doom he's pretty [ __ ]
fascinating you can make a whole movie
about him and stuff I think it's smart
play it's good at being that guy ya know
one all did [ __ ] Fargo TV series and
Legion and Legion as well
I trust him then I'd like that Fargo
shows so good I'd let that dude [ __ ] my
wife oh my god so I'll definitely trust
him with Doctor Doom for sure he take a
while to get there another white day but
it'd be interesting to watch just thing
is [ __ ] a ton of speeches and the whole
time I'd be like I wonder if people from
the movie are gonna show up and I mean
we can kick plug in valerian well it's
down if we want what is happening well I
don't want to keep the land looks
imagine it to nobody else thinks so
really somebody just got boo simply see
it I feel like [ __ ] that trailer
did anybody anybody in the room see
valerian
you did and it was pretty it's beautiful
but choppy that editor the end of the
leads are too young really God Anna this
trailers looks fantastic and I like him
I'm always kind of rooting for him a
filmmaker he pushes and pushes it cost a
hundred eighty million dollars and made
sixteen and its opening weekend Oceania
I came out everything Wow I read an
article came out like two three weeks
ago he's doing an interview and the
movie wasn't tracking huge then but he
was saying look the son you know he's
got that company Europa film Corp
there's old period of time where he
stopped direct and just started
producing movies get movies financed
that's where the takin series comes from
us where the transporters I what it's
called series comes from those like
action movies and stuff so he like made
money built up his own loot and [ __ ]
like that and he always loved this movie
the book as a kid he always wanted to do
it and he did the fifth element because
it's he felt that's as close as he could
it was his version of valerian and then
years later after seeing avatar he's
like oh my god anything's possible we
could do valerian and make it look
exactly a conflict he's been on a Vision
Quest his whole life since he you know
saw it so he hedged his bets and made
sure that he was covered he resold it
like the movie and all these territories
so he's only according to the article he
says words himself he said he was only
on the hook personally for seven million
dollars the movie only had to make seven
million bucks at the box office for him
to be whole so I don't think it's a
financial disaster is it you know is he
[ __ ] breaking the bank apparently not
but like you got a plot somebody is
going to swing that wide like maybe it
didn't [ __ ] mail or hit the V of the
way he wanted it to but he's trying
something he's like The Mirror Universe
James Cameron mmm who liked to Cameron
swings [ __ ] wide and
they always hit yeah he's like blue cats
what do you [ __ ] triple let me try
that again
blue cat you [ __ ] with their ponytails
[Laughter]
yeah there's no pasando no that's a
bummer how much it'd make what's the
figure 16 million domestic cost 180 and
what does anything else open this
weekend Dunkirk
now as I imagine did quite well 50
million is what is tracking it yes I
mean for I know you know of course it's
not like a dark night opening for Chris
Nolan and stuff it probably puts it in
the range of well inception I think
opened like bigger but that's Leo
DiCaprio and I felt like a ton bigger
like inception opened they granted it
was 10 years ago but it opened like 45
Tom but was in the top 10 for 30 weeks
really yeah like it had legs like you
wouldn't [ __ ] believe it had
Wonderwoman legs Wonder Woman is the is
the strongest holding superhero movie of
all time the drop from week to week is
so small and I had we talked about it
when it first when we first saw it we
were like every summer there's a movie
that comes along that just sustains that
like people keep bringing other people
to go see it and wonder where was that
thing like every every woman went to go
see it was like hey you girl crew we are
totally [ __ ] going to see this Jesus
girl squad roll out Wonder Woman time so
like this 50 million is about par for
the course when Chris Nolan makes a
thing that is not a Batman movie it's
cuz it in what was the sci-fi movie
interstellar interstellar around it
seemed like it debuted in that kind of
territory but I mean I'm not much on the
war films but it looked pretty amazing
to the point where I you know I
understand he's a big enthusiast of
seeing a movie in a theater and
70-millimeter and stuff he may have sold
me on this movie you know I saw a few
people on Twitter going like oh my god
it was like you were there and somebody
else said something that really made me
want to go see it they were like if you
thought the score
in the dark night was relentless wait
until you see this movie it never lets
up so I don't know I mean I haven't seen
a single bad thing about it I've never
seen anybody go you know people are like
oh my god is what cinema is about and
for so I look forward to seeing it and
that's the number-one movie yeah
on comic-con weekend well in hell you
know he counts he's [ __ ] the director
of The Dark Knight he's that guy yeah
and they also market it that way like
from the director of The Dark Knight
boring-ass history wish it you've never
heard of yeah it's true I had to explain
to my kids who's like what's it about
and I was like well if I understand the
trailer correctly like I don't know
British history I don't know World War
two history at all and she's like what
so what do you understand it as well as
I do I was like yeah what'd you get out
of it she's like a lot of people getting
hurt and I was like all right well there
you go
war is hell kid there's a lesson for the
day carry on what else we go that is it
my friend that was the list that's the
news bucket I'm trying to think what
else happened what are the other news
announcements man anybody else got
anything that happened that we Kingsman
trailer happened and they also had a
panel how did it look to everybody
people seem to be losing their goddamn
minds over the Kingsmen I'm tell him and
that first one snuck up on me
and it shouldn't have because I liked
all the players involved and also behind
the scenes as Mark Millar book right
here ton and Matthew Vaughn and Emmett
and I've been
Matthew Vaughn insanely talented but
Mark Millar man like I love I've loved
him says from the world of comics I've
loved him since he took over Swamp Thing
he did a run at Swamp Thing back in the
day that was really keyed in to the old
Alan Moore run I was like I like to cut
of this guy's jib I like his style so
for years like I've kind of watched his
stuff and I remember like he'd ask a lot
any kind of madam or talk to him he's
always asking about movies and settlers
like how cute for this guy he likes
movies good for him this poor comic-book
guy he'll never get near a movie but
good for him and [ __ ] like that
cuts it today like he has created his
own universe of films and they're viable
you know how tough it is just create a
new comic book that takes off let alone
takes off of the feature and they've
been able to do that with him and
Matthew Vaughn with kick-ass and then
with Kingsman as well and that [ __ ]
sequence in the you know of the killing
in the church in the first movie is it
as good as a cinematic sequence as
anything you'd see in Deadpool is
anything you would see and maybe even I
haven't seen you know Dunkirk but
anything [ __ ] known so it was a
wonder it was fantastic it reminds me of
like old John Woo movies like we are
going to put a bunch of people in an
enclosed space and shoot for a month and
then we will deliver unto you a thing
you've never seen before
yeah and the enclosed space isn't just
like four walls of green and then we're
going to add a stark sky and a ring of
garbage later on like it's there
shooting an actual physical place with
the SF which helps yeah I like that's
like quite a bit I haven't seen her or
the new panel and I didn't get to watch
the new trailer has anybody else noticed
that like it's impossible to get
anything done online in San Diego these
four days because everybody in the world
who uses the Internet is here this
weekend and so we're all hitting it the
same [ __ ] time and the toughest is
crazy thank God I wasn't a horror movie
about to get killed and I'm trying to
get serviced and [ __ ] like toughest it
was I've ever had experience getting
anything loaded online was trying to
watch the Justice League trailer two
hours to [ __ ] load it man so I was
like I'm gonna love the [ __ ] out of
there yeah thank God it was four minutes
it's like a big chunk so I felt like
alright well maybe that makes sense I
took so long but yeah it's tough to get
a signal here menu
yeah gave up I just I just went dark or
just [ __ ] it send me a raven if you need
to dump alright what else you guys want
talking about Star Trek did anybody see
the new stuff that they show you did
let's hear about it is it so this is
Star Trek show that's going to debut on
CBS but moved to the CBS app channel
this is that where they start making you
pay for your love of Star Trek it's not
I mean his generations of social
outcasts 'dom yeah and now you got to
pay money what it looked like who's
playing who and who did they get to
originally it was going to be the guy
that did Hannibal right Brian Cole who
stepped away who stepped away Michelle
Yeoh is a captain okay Jason Isaac and
man from the patriot Jason Isaac yeah I
like [ __ ] I'm a drink'll Malfoy's -
the one white guy in the world that can
pull off the name Lucius it's true true
he's gay I was then I met him one night
I was in a we were in Las Vegas and back
in the down what they do it anymore
but video was a big business back then
video software dealers association the
BSD a those are the people that ordered
the videotapes and the you know and the
Malignaggi
that went into every mom-and-pop store a
lot of people here are young so a
videotape kids is it old form of
Technology so they would have these
shows and you know Miramax is in the
business of like him and we'll make a
lot of noise they were like the Marvel
films of Marvel Comics of indie film
they made a lot of noise to call
attention to themselves so Harvey and
Bob understood the importance of like
let's bring these filmmakers and their
titles to Vegas and have them get up and
talk and I could sign autographs and
[ __ ] like that so I did it a few times
you go out and you meet the people and
stuff so this particular occasion I
forget which movie I was there for but
apparently the Patriot was out around
the same time so maybe chasing amy may
be dog might forget so we wound up
having to be stuck in the same car
together to go speak at this event and
he was like insanely charming and funny
and I was in total spectator mode I
wasn't trying to compete or be funny at
all I was just like oh my god man I live
in that voice all day
everything he was saying was like dry
and witty and [ __ ] like that and he kept
calling me Kevin I like that is like
this guy's [ __ ] famous he's calling
me Kevin isn't that right Kevin I think
he's right British man like so you know
I was more like I certainly wasn't sound
about but I certainly wasn't on in show
mode in the car and so we get to the
event and stuff and they're like okay
the order is this and this and then
Kevin Smith you go
and then jason isaacs and you go and so
he goes do you have anything I've
prepared before we go up there because
these things always make me nervous but
I just try to play them off cool I work
off a little script and stuff
he goes you have anything prepared and I
was like no I'm just going to now just
go up and [ __ ] wing it and say hi and
stuff like and he goes well good luck
mate and so you know the leg and now the
director of this [ __ ] this guy and they
bring me out and once I'm in front of an
audience like [ __ ] bang you know it's
like flipping a switch and [ __ ] and I'm
like total entertainment mode so I went
out and literally crushed like I went
into the charming stories of being the
guy that's [ __ ] you know made clerks
and [ __ ] like that now to get the cat to
[ __ ] on cue and whatever to [ __ ] in the
audience like how we saw Clark's and and
so [ __ ] I went out and then you know
I'm not bragging but I [ __ ] killed by
nobody expected this guy to kill I got
him know is he's a fat guy yep and then
they're like oh [ __ ] he's funny so I
came off [ __ ] stage and Jason who had
spent like an hour with the last hour
with in a car and [ __ ] like that being
his audience looks at me so betrayed and
he goes you said five things in the
limousine and I think I was getting
ready for my show dude and he goes oh my
god how am I supposed to follow that he
threw out his little strip using I'm
saying [ __ ] a lot you know
[Laughter]
[Applause]
funny guy man I'm so happy I'm happy
here he's in it what is it again I've
lost the thread of our Trek discovery
Star Trek
alright so [ __ ] whatever yeah I can
put my money where my mouth is and
support that app I didn't know that I
was going to necessarily watch that show
but I kind of I want to support that
model I like the idea that they're like
alright we're putting something here
exclusively and they know they're going
to train us to use it but like they got
us over about we got something you want
to watch but we already used to do and
that we do it with Netflix some of us do
it with to a lesser degree with Hulu so
this is just yet another kind of like I
we want your [ __ ] 10 bucks this month
and they might get it because I I hope
that continues that's one more place for
creators to make new stuff like the
beautiful thing about digital is it's
not just like the three networks or the
cable networks or the movie studios
there's a whole new crop of people who
are like hey we need your stories we
need your content and that's one more
place to try to apply your wares so to
speak so I hope it takes off I might
actually even though I'm not the world's
biggest Star Trek fan I might actually
sign up just to kind of support the
thing also hearing that you liked it as
a strong big Star Trek person so you're
like me you're more of a Star Wars guy
and stuff are you [ __ ] serious look
how well trained I am they're like you
know it has to do with the past I'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding me
I'm from the past it's the road woman
Star Trek it really kind of so is this
is this is happening how long before
Kirk and Spock oh my god I want this so
badly that's [ __ ] smart now that's
how you get me I'm like [ __ ] CEREC I
know that guy
that's dope that means they could do
[ __ ] like you know again if nobody wants
to watch the show like we got our
desperate move they could do the 15 year
old Kirk episodes or something like that
and the young Spock as well
[ __ ] dude you do it a better job of
selling me the show than CBS Pacific
what else what else do people see an
effing spawn
let's hit spawn then we'll jump over
there spawn I'm so happy for Todd
McFarlane he announced it on the boat he
came on the boat and did it during a
Facebook live Todd McFarlane creator of
spawn for years has been trying to get a
spawn movie put together another spawn
movie made and just recently like not
too long ago within the last month I
would say month and a half Todd was a
discount braggy but Todd was over my
house we were talking about an unrelated
project that is somewhat related he's
doing we're doing a hopefully be doing a
salmon twitch series as you know over at
BBC America and that's predicated on the
salmon to its characters that he created
for the spawn universe so we spent more
time together as of late and stuff and
he was over the house he was talking
about I'm in here in town and I'm gonna
go talk to a bunch of people and find
the right guy maybe to partner up with
produced to spawn movie and stuff he's
from Canada so I was like well what are
you looking for a big budget now's the
time to do it man like people love these
comic book movies be amazing time make a
giant [ __ ] spawn movie because I don't
want to do a giant spawn movies like
they did that already he's going I want
to make a small spawn movie I want to
make a low-budget horror movie about
spawn it's a movie where like the
shadows pop to life and stuff it's not
about big capes and stuff taking it to
its horror element and he's like I want
to keep a low budget because then I can
direct it if it's an 80 million dollar
movie they'll never let me near it this
is my character so I was like man like
well that's smart as you should go talk
to Jason Blum the God does Blum house
man because I think I'm having a meeting
with him I was like he seems like the
perfect match because he's just coming
off split which turned out to be a
backdoor superhero movie that was tied
to unbreakable and they just announced
glass
this weekend as well so jason blum who
does all this but oh you're right they
got very excited about glass or very mad
about glass I swallowed a glass but but
I was like those flex man think about
like you know guys to get out just
happen and they did a great job with
that Blum House does all these very
low-budget flicks that trucking do well
and stuff you're talking about doing a
low-budget version of Spawn it is like
you wanted to ahora version Jason does
Armos you should really talk to him
about it I think I might comes on the
boat month and a half later this weekend
todd mcfarlane ego announces that he's
making spawn with jason blum the plum
house a low-budget horror version of it
like five to ten million bucks that he
gets to write and direct himself so it's
so happy for him so happy number one for
every spawn fanners like finally we've
been waiting since 97 20 years for
another spawn movie and he's held on to
it other people wanted to do it but he's
wanted to do it himself and if he
finally waited to a point long enough in
time we found the right financing entity
the right producer is like I'll [ __ ]
totally take a chance on you man you got
a long tail and he created this [ __ ]
like why not you they let kevin smith
direct movies why not you and so he gets
to make a flick thoughts on that i tell
you anything low-budget is super smart
because i honest in it is really smart
because I honestly don't know what the
audience respond movie is
right in the same way that I know
exactly what the audience is for a
Wonder Woman movie so like to minimize
your risk to keep your your overhead low
[ __ ] it yeah if you make twenty on a ten
million dollar movie like that's a win
it is and you can keep going - yeah and
once again it's all about control you
got you're talking about a lot of the
people who created these characters that
we all love have no control over them a
novena they did is work for ire and so
like whatever happens to those
characters they they may not have a hand
in in the future and you know it's got
to be heartbreaking if you're like comic
book writer to watch like some of your
best material wind up in somebody else's
hands and turn into their story I guess
you're used to it because you watch the
characters the characters were given the
you and you'll give them to somebody
else you're just there for a moment but
in the case of Todd he created spawn and
created the entire universe and stuff
and at one point like in the 90s to get
a movie made like there's no way they
would have let a helmet I'm sure he was
excited to see that movie happen but
having been through it and seeing the
process and been the business as long as
the guy came to the obvious and
brilliant observation that like I want
to do this like I know this character
bathed than anybody else and and he had
this really interesting kind of point in
the room we were talking he goes because
I was like well will people accept that
as a spawn movie if it's not big-budget
and he goes well I created spawn so I
say what a spawn movie is and I was like
[ __ ] a Canada you know so I look
forward to that I think is a good move
for him all right where do we want to go
next you pick stranger things
stranger things yes I I met some of the
cast of including the the boy from
Vancouver Finn most metal name at
comic-con Finn wolfhard who's a sweet
sweet [ __ ] kid man he's also in it so
like yeah he's got the [ __ ] kid
market with like locked up right now he
was a realtor for our kids
wexter flower kids what have you heard
about strange of things season 2 you
know you talked to these cats you like
tell us something about like we can't
we'll get in trouble
that apparently was a totality of the
panel was oh I did get something out of
it go ahead you tell me it was like
Patton Oswalt sitting up there being
charming as Patton Oswalt does but kept
on asking looking into my season two and
they say I can't say anything so yeah
but what about in season two's like no
we can't say anything but season two is
gonna be cool right we can't say
anything it was that for like 45 minutes
man we had a dude on the boat who's
joining this season his first season on
stranger things so I asked a question
and it the other two kids they were on
last season it was a fence sister and
her boyfriend and sure like that so you
know we lovely kids and so the new guy
I I asked a question I was like hey I
read the duffer brothers gave you all
specific movies or movie scenes to watch
to prepare because a lot of these kids
in the show not just little kids but
even their older teen siblings as you
they weren't even a lot of in the
eighties one of them was like I was born
in 92 I'm like what the [ __ ] that was
you were come when I made clerks you
know so so they talked about like I was
like I heard like you know stand by me
was a reference point and they were the
other two like yeah they gave us like
you know different scenes specifically
cold pop cultural touchstones she said
for my character there's a lot of pretty
and big sixteen Candles and stuff like
then but I said okay well I was season
one what can you tell us about the
reference material did they give you
more reference material for season two
like these are the flavors to look at
you know and the two of them were like
well you know we can't say and the new
guy was just like they told me to watch
The Shining a lot right that's what I
[ __ ] said and I go really goes yeah
they told me to look a lot of Jack
Nicholson movies particularly The
Shining so take from that what you will
he said in the interview so yeah yeah
the trailer is very uh it's like there's
a bunch of [ __ ] having the sky there's a
bunch of upside down that you get to see
the thing that blew me away was I'm not
sure you guys understand how much it
costs to get a Michael Jackson song in a
trailer yeah and it ends with Thriller
and that's like a ten million dollar buy
yeah to get that [ __ ] song for a
trailer yeah but your Netflix you like
keep the change
I mean think about all of us everybody
who has Netflix we all paid for that
[ __ ] song but you won't argue when
you watch the trailer we like talk
that's a perfect use of that song
they're playing that game big time now
man like in marketing used to be you
know you have a new song attached to a
movie that was on the radio and was
driving the soundtrack and stuff and so
it was fresh and new now it's a back
sell like you watched the Thor trailer
the first one you know is the immigrant
song and stuff like that which you know
cost a [ __ ] ton of money but it's Disney
and Marvel so they're like how much you
want you know and I just [ __ ] give
them all the money this is a case of
Netflix who has all the money in the
world going like what can we do just to
see if we could do it like I know let's
put a Michael Jackson song in a trailer
and they're like oh my god let's see how
much that would cost how much 10 million
we'll give you 20 [ __ ] off that works
what else we got what else did you guys
do in humans I've heard in humans four
times did you I met with the cast of the
Inhumans are absolutely loved no they
were absolutely lovely and Jeph Loeb was
with him as well and so we talked about
the show I'm on board I actually I
remember seeing the trailer online and
reacted like oh okay I guess that's our
way to go and you could tell with the TV
show like you know they'd have as much
money as the movie theater but when I
put the movie versions when I went to a
movie theater to see spider-man
homecoming second time they played the
Inhumans trailer in front of it and
maybe it's me and I'm an idiot but I
like to consider myself something of a
visual storyteller I thought it looked
so much better I watched spider-man on a
big IMAX screen I thought it looked
better on the IMAX screen it felt like
it was composed for that some of the
problems people seem to be having with
it visually and again you're talking to
the guy who should never argue for
anyone's visuals or anything like that
because you can argue for his own but to
me it looked like it looked good on the
IMAX screen like I said they're gone I
was probably gonna watch it at home but
I might actually support this in
theaters
you know as it has been explained to me
by by people in the world they had about
six weeks to build this show because the
way I max works is they have two windows
over Memorial Day window and a and a
Labor Day window okay when there's
nothing on IMAX screen so they went to
Marvel and said hey do you want to do a
show we could premiere in Labor Day and
I'm experienced and this was like June
as though I guess we can make a show in
six weeks sure we don't need time
we're Marvel we could do any we do
anything we put a teleporting dog and
that [ __ ] we're done yeah it just it's
one of those like I would way rather
seen a Hawkeye show than in a human show
hmm like if I got a pick from the list
of [ __ ] I could get from Marvel I don't
ever get to Inhumans really dashes me
they probably just a shield like agent
shields actually really solid show I
never get a Hawkeye show though because
he's cinematic universe so you got you
know maybe yeah they gotta kill him I do
in a world where you're like they though
they might kill Captain America he's got
to go first he's just like a [ __ ]
he's a match he might never show up he's
just killing off-screen did you imagine
that
what happened Hawkeye remember he died
off-camera
he won't be missed yet who to go back to
remember yeah what else we want to talk
about oh that guy say it again games
broke Game of Thrones I said earlier
that did I mention it or did I mention
that elsewhere I think it was here
I spoke to liam Cunningham who played
ser Davos he gave no spoilers what so
everybody told a very charming story
about the you know the little stag that
Davos carved out and gave to the
princess Shireen he said I I actually
stole that from set my liver he didn't
say so he I liberated it from set and I
took it home and I gave it to my
daughter and put it on her shelf with
all of her awesome things she calls them
or whatever and you know then when it
showed up in the television show first
time you know you see him carving then
giving it to her we watched the show
together and she was crying because she
understood the sentiment woman he's like
and then the next time we watched it
together as Shireen being you know taken
to the steak and burned with the toy in
her hand and he's like my daughter looks
up at me all of a sudden trying to
understand what's going on it's kind of
funny story man he was a lovely [ __ ]
guy gave a lot of great content talked
for like 12 minutes and was sweet as you
want him to be I love that character
he's the soul of the show and I asked
how I said to him I was like look
there's a world where all these [ __ ]
kill each other and you wind up on the
Iron Throne and he goes you know
sometimes we sit around in costume on
set and play a game where we just look
at each other and be like it's you feel
like we don't even [ __ ] know
so we just play that game like everybody
else who is it was cool but that's all I
heard were there any other news bites
that how do I think it's going to end in
Ice and Fire
yeah I hear there was a george RR martin
said that it has a not the show but the
story itself
has a bittersweet ending so that to me
sounds like I'll be satisfied to a
degree but I gotta be honest with you I
can't ask for much more than that show
it is very nearly perfect and also it is
granted to of my my wishes like over the
run of that show like heartfelt desires
but I never expressed that lap it was
like please please if there is a God and
a Jesus let this happen
they killed Joffrey and Ramsay like I I
hated both of those fictional boys more
than I've hated any living human being
in my life so [ __ ] much and it was so
satisfying when both of them went I was
surprised by the one I know they take
Joffrey out and [ __ ] take him out
with poison and [ __ ] I was like oh my
god he's turning blue oh my god is dead
what a great day you know and then
[ __ ] Ramsay got his face chewed off
by the [ __ ] dog and I was like well
that's [ __ ] poetic justice my wife's
like snow that's good writing you know
okay you're absolutely right so I love
that [ __ ] right there
even if they were like eh we can never
satisfy you as well as that again even
if at the end of it the final shot is
the [ __ ] the night king sitting on
the [ __ ] throne going surprised you
know I'll [ __ ] take it I don't give a
[ __ ] because they've given me so many
big [ __ ] satisfying moments that as
storytellers must have been tempting to
not give you know because they can kind
of go their own way a little bit on the
show particularly the last two seasons
so they really could kept that Ramsay
[ __ ] going for a long time and it would
have been for me like being in a bad
relationship with somebody where I'm
like I can't hate you but I can't quit
you you know so I'm glad they took him
out of my life the character the guy is
lovely I talked to him on the boat me so
is the opposite of [ __ ] Ramsay as you
would imagine but I was glad to see
those characters go so if they don't
give me what I want at the end it's okay
but who do I want on the Iron Throne if
I had to pick mmm
yes guy I think it's got to be Daenerys
has got to be sleazy I think so her
story like any other I'm tempted at
moments to be like Tyrion that'd be
amazing and stuff but it's been it's
been her journey the whole time you know
watching her go from beggar Queen to
ruler of all the Andals in the Seven
Kingdoms which I loved in the last
episode when Jamie was just like three
at best thrown shaded a cistern shits
last lover
it's got lost in that thought like they
[ __ ] each other you got any thoughts on
G ot uh I want aria on the son who Arya
Stark is she in contention uh as much as
anybody is I think I think Daenerys gets
she gets hit for for hubris I think I
think there's the like I am V these the
Oathbreaker I am the slave freer I am
all of this [ __ ] like the wheel there is
there's a sense that she's a little bit
too big for her lazy britches so they
might give her like a Moses ending where
it's like you're going to get within
sight of it and you'll never he said on
the throne but I think this entire
story's been leading us to a stark on
the throne really yeah I mean would you
be satisfied if it was Jon Snow oh yeah
I get there I get was he but I I like I
know that I'm sorry I do love Jon Snow
but at the same time it's like put
somebody on the throne that's got a
dragon [ __ ] that's how you rule man you
like look I'm a peaceful ruler but if
you get out of line [ __ ] Jakarta soon
[ __ ] it's all over what if Clea gives
him a dragon you're right then I love
Jon Snow he's got his own dragon and
[ __ ] well how are they were they're
related right now half brother half
sibling
she's his Anne those are two different
things
so she hold on let's do this lineage
because she is not even going to play
y'all have fun
that's he is Raigarh son and regards her
brother all right
and the Mad King was her father but
what's the Matt King Jon Snow like an
uncle grandfather all right fair enough
I'm back on board thank you I'm all
caught up carry on what else we want to
talk about hold on well as the lady says
that well done oh that what happy
they're making Grant Morrison's happy
grin Morrison came to my house a couple
times to do Batman Batman who has it
come to your house Kevin Feige a more
can I got to stop hugging him so much
John him this is Spielberg that would be
a good whoo okay so who came to - Grant
Morrison he's coming to excellent
episodes of fat man I'm Batman when it
was the one on one interview version of
the show one of the smartest people he
over me great thinker fantastic [ __ ]
artist brilliant writer and stuff like
that boy it was such a build-up I forgot
oh so he comes over and he brings a gift
a second time he comes over I brought
you something you know I'm not going to
do the whole [ __ ] accident but he's
got that pickaxe and don't what you
should he's like don't get and it had it
had a donkey on the cover he gave his
comic book called happy because this is
my favorite thing I'm doing right now
and that's pretty good I was yeah thank
you was channeling Trainspotting right
there I was in Highlander for a second
he was very proud of his like and he
explained what the story was like this
is going on in this dude's head he's got
this little donkey that talks to himself
he's like I love it
and then BAM all of a sudden I read that
it's actually being turned into a TV
show and the guy who's playing who's in
it I can't even I don't want to spoil
what he plays but there's a guy in it
who was in Joe Wright man his name is
I've known for years wonderful guy you'd
recognize if you've ever seen a Kevin
Smith movie you ever saw Jay and Silent
Bob strike back he's the guy that's
standing next to Chris Rock when Chris
Rock owes this movie is going to make
house party look like house party - and
he goes for house party 3 Chris I shut
the [ __ ] up he goes yes sir
that's the guy so I saw him on the boat
and I was like just [ __ ] saw your
name in the press they announce that you
got cast and Happy's like I did I did
it's a big thing for me that that show
has a home at all is a big deal and the
fact that like they're rewarding his
genius because he is so [ __ ] bright
grant and some of this stuff is just so
far ahead of like what you can pull off
or what you can convey in traditional
media it's nice to see they found a way
to take this this madcap idea and make
it real where is it going to be areas of
sci-fi sci-fi sci-fi so hats off to them
yeah and big swing and Patton Oswalt is
voicing happy Italy yeah that's [ __ ]
cool placing Bobby Moynihan and I don't
know why oh really I'll be morning's got
that show he just got he's leaving SNL
you know why I'm as my guest I'm just
doing with my Jessica Fletcher detective
work he left SNL and he's got a new
sitcom coming up so maybe he's like I
can't split time or something like that
lazy but that's the happy this I love
this version where it's like you shout
out [ __ ] and I'll tell your story what
else what else hold on back there going
red red ROM is that the kid from the
shining Frank Miller I didn't see Frank
Miller the show did you what Frank
Miller's doing Superman year one on
romita jr. jr. what yeah John Romita Jr
and Frank Miller doing some a new one
also Superboy basically probably that's
where is right it's fantastic so wait
the idea is like Dark Knight or well
Batman year one but for Superman
wow man why not do it with magic Kelly
well because jrjr is amazing guys an
embarrassment of riches when you're
Frank Miller you probably got a lot of
people who choose from yeah I'm good I
saw him on the floor as you pick him up
I could have he weighs like a pumpkin
soaking wet yeah he's been do yeah he
looks as old as Stan Lee and he's 30
years younger than Stan Lee know that
right that's some hard [ __ ] living my
friend
he lives like the Batman born again born
again Derrick [ __ ] it never mind
moving on alright Blade Runner did you
see anything from Blade Runner no I
interviewed Denny bills you built
Kathryn he said is the luck kept ingénue
so bill newb I've always been gone good
news and it still new Denny Villeneuve
who directed Blade Runner 20 49 and
arrival and if that's what I talked to
him about the most because he was like I
cannot tell you that much about Blade
Runner you know we talked about
generalities I'm about Ridley I was like
look [ __ ] weird walking in somebody's
shoes he's a Bruce of the movie was he
there every day going it's not Blade
Runner enough and sure like that he was
like now he wasn't even I could not have
done this movie if he was looking over
my shoulder though time be trusted me
and I went forward with his vision but I
would tell you it is very hard to take
somebody else's vision and bring it to
life in the future when he showed us a
vision of the future and the past this
is like the International House of
Pancakes accent these guys that is my
french-canadian exes from Quebec or
Montreal so he he said to me I you know
I was like look man I [ __ ] love
arrival and I blew him about arrival for
a long time and stuff and we went deep
diving on arrival until the great stuff
but then I got to ask him about I was
like I hear you after this is done like
after blade runner's out your life you
might be heading to do and he is he's
heading to do next she's like I've
always loved this since I was a kid I
was what about the Lynch version he goes
I respect David as an artist but I did
not see dune when I saw that I there
things that need to be there that are
doing and I think I could do it and so
that dudes gone what a dream life dude
he went from a Blade Runner sequel to a
[ __ ] he might go to a dune remake
that guy's talented man he did Sicario
if you've not seen a rival take the time
to watch it at first it's a little
frustrating if you're not a smart I'm
not very smart at all so soon they're
going what the [ __ ] going on you know
kept asking my wife I'm through that
little girl and she liked that but then
when the movie comes together and and
nobody had given me any help whatsoever
I smell I felt like a big boy I was
mark and I figured it out for myself and
I was real emotional it's a crazy
[ __ ] good movie I told them I was
like dude that movie is B I'll work hard
my entire life I'll work I'll never make
anything as [ __ ] beautiful as that
film so human and so humane it's a movie
about technically about aliens so I got
to blow him up about it but he wouldn't
give me many details on Blade Runner
except to say that Ryan Gosling was a
true collaborator he's gone I think of
Ryan as a co-author on this he
differently had ideas of what he wanted
to do and it informed what the final
product was didya did Ryan explain
robots to him like jazz no no I didn't
that I didn't think to ask any
la-la-land question like hey made you
see Lala's like yes it is a movie that
beat arrival at the Oscars so [ __ ] your
lalala alright what else we got whoo
preacher frickin boost Jose I heard
nothing about moocs Jose here preacher
what did I hear about preacher I talked
to the cast on the boat they were lovely
I talked to Seth on the boat as well but
we talked about not just preacher and
his ability to pull it off I blew him up
for that I was like him in like when did
you make the decision like was it it was
a conscious effort to go from like being
the guy in the Apatow movies which were
insanely successful you could have done
that for the rest of your life to being
the guys not only directing the movies
as well but like making other [ __ ] like
having produced things made case in
point
preacher you know and he had a great
philosophy I thought he goes you know we
just always a man Evan is trying to go
Berg their work buddies so we always
just feel like like if we don't do it
then we'll be stuck watching the version
that sucks so we might as well get to it
first otherwise we're going to watch
something we don't like he's like it's
really selfish he's going but it keeps
me driven you know and keeps moving
forward what else did he talk about he
said there's no plans for another
sausage party immediately
and he said there was a reason he's gone
we don't really believe in sequels that
much he's gone you know I think a lot of
the audience likes what we do because we
go new places each time it's not the
same thing and he's gone you know we did
neighbors too and it didn't really work
out so we're kind of gun-shy about doing
sequels right now which I thought was
interesting at the end of sausage party
it's like alright well here comes the
sequel and he's like man and then we
talk about disaster artists have you
seen the trailer for disaster artists
yet looks amazing take your time if you
haven't seen it I mean you know for some
people like I don't get it this shit's
too culty there's this Tommy Wiseau
movie called the room which has a very
very hardcore following particularly in
this world and whatnot and Seth produced
and Jacob Franco's James Franco is
playing and I think he directed I think
Frankie directed this he did right and
Franco's a filmmaker legit filmmaker man
like he and he's been doing it for years
sometimes louder sometimes stealth but
he's always taken like money from the
big movies I don't know this because
Mosier Scott Mosier was his editor for
years he took his spider-man money and
put it into making films like on his own
we all know him as artsy fartsy dozens
iliyan things you like hey [ __ ] there's
James Franco he showed up on a [ __ ]
soap opera hey there's James Franco he's
teaching out of college
hey that barista was James Franco but
but he's kept his hand in the directing
game in a big bad way so this trailer
like looks like a movie that can win
awards like it doesn't look like a bunch
of people goofing on what the room was
they're telling a story about the joy of
moviemaking I asked about it and he was
talking about like the idea that like
we're all obsessed with this movie like
we all talk about how it's the worst
movie ever made but I've seen that movie
more than I've seen good movies like
I've seen all the President's Men once
I've seen the room a hundred times he's
gone so what does that mean why why do
we keep watching it stuff but the movie
looks like it's going to be a
celebration like kind of like Ed Wood
and he said that was kind of our model
the idea of people were like have all
the passion but none of the talent a
little bit Bowfinger something like that
but this was a real-life example that
had happened so Franco is playing one
izo and looks kind of pitch perfect I
mean like Franco is a beautiful [ __ ]
dude and he got as close to wise though
as he could without leaving his face
entirely the trailer is really [ __ ]
funny it's real it's just a it's a movie
beat it's been trying to shoot one line
of dialogue and he can't get the line of
dialogue right they just go to multiple
takes multiple takes and when he finally
gets it right it's like one of the worst
deliveries in cinema history and
everybody on set they're just so
delighted they finally got it they're
like well they start celebrating and so
it's fantastic little piece of
filmmaking so he talked about that as
well I talked about future man he's got
a show that's going to lululu that's
kind of predicated on the idea of like
it's not taken from this but last
starfighter
you know the idea of somebody so good at
something they need you in the future to
save the world or some so he's having a
good old [ __ ] time and easily could
have rode out on a career of just being
the funny guy in them in somebody else's
movie but decided with his friend you
know he's been friends with forever to
captain his own thing man and bam there
donut so I always love talking to him
because I remember I met that guy in
transition my god zack and miri you can
tell he was the guy building that he
talked about that movie future of the TV
show future man when it was a movie they
wanted to do while we were making zack
and miri so I loved watching him kind of
come to fruition and build his [ __ ] and
then sit and talking to him was kind of
fun but we talked a little bit about
preacher not blow them up going like
with all your juice and power and stuff
you you did almost be impossible you got
preacher made like you know you easily
could have been like let's do our own
stuff but you [ __ ] you found a way to
get preacher made and he goes well that
was selfish too he's gone we always
loved preacher we didn't want somebody
else to [ __ ] it up but a gave us chance
to practice at our filmmaking he's like
we're new we haven't done it a lot we've
only made a couple movies but when
you're making a TV show particularly TV
show like preacher you get to try a
bunch of different things so it was
smart as well like you know wasn't just
like oh we just wanna see preacher it
was also a mini film school for him I
thought that was kind of interesting
maybe not you guys but I thought that
was really [ __ ] interesting but that
was all I knew about preacher I know
it's coming back and I know it's we kept
talking about how it's this this year
you guys are on the road and
like except we don't go anywhere so take
that for what it means
who was the every every time I go to
comic-con there's like a moment for me
that defines what comic-con is did you
have one of those this year what was my
defining moment of comic-con no I don't
think honestly I spent a lot of time
talking to people and I was on the boat
I mean periodically on the boat that the
line for Hall H wraps down the dock and
so they were right in front of the boat
and I was on the top floor interviewing
people and stuff and then periodically
you would just hear people go like Kevin
and I turn around a wave and then a
bunch of people like and you know I'd
smile and wave and then kind of go back
to working stuff and then we worked it
out to a place where I forget who was I
talking to somebody pretty [ __ ]
famous and somebody in the background
was like God and you know we're in the
middle of the interview and [ __ ] instead
of turning like I'm talking to the
person the person's talking to me and
sitting there going like this they go
off camera from the doctor and I go and
stay in the [ __ ] conversation so I
had little moments like that but no I
can't think of one giant moment I mean I
I don't know if I'm supposed to say this
because for speed you know what I did I
do have a defining moment of contella
it happened literally before the show we
all watched screen junkies honest
trailers and stuff like that screen
junkies I loved there the people over
there I loved the platform I loved
everything they do and stuff so they do
show called movie fights and and they
invited me to come play and so they told
me it was going to be you versus Elijah
Wood and I was like oh [ __ ] man bring it
on ain't no Eagles to rescue his ass you
know
so it was me Elijah and Dan was on the
show and stuff and Andy was the you know
the guy reads the question the show is
for Matt's pretty simple like they tell
you in advance like what you're going to
advocate for let me read you with my
prep the basic prep for this the
questions that were sent to me papa blah
blah okay round one who's the greatest
living film maker so you just have to
come up with that and you have to be
able to argue your point so whatever you
say you have to be able to argue and the
other two guys have different opinions
and they argue and stuff against you you
can knock other people's arguments
sounds like debate club and [ __ ] round
two what comic book movie of our time
will be most celebrated in 50 years
right good question round three scariest
movie scene of all time and then round
four 13th anniversary of Eternal
Sunshine of the spotless mind is this
year if you could permanently erase one
movie from all of existence which would
it be why actually my first inclination
was Jersey girl but this is but this is
a game that gets scored there are points
and stuff like that and so I come to
plac come to win this movie fights I
don't want to leave movie loser I only
movie winner and stuff so I play much
more strategically than most so for
round one these are my answers for round
one they asked who is the greatest
living film maker okay and I picked
Kevin Feige and they picked like Elijah
picked Steven Spielberg and Dan picked
Scorsese and I was like that's those
guys are great directors but the
question was specifically filmmakers and
that's much broader and my argument was
like the Marvel Universe's have what 16
movies in 10 years
that is one sprawling story and there's
one puppet master one storyteller behind
all that and these are the stories that
I [ __ ] love and I'll pay cash money
leave my fat ass will leave my house go
to a movie theater and sit there and
watch those movies because I like them
so much I was like so that guy to me is
is the the greatest living film maker
good and so those two dudes you know one
at me like come on they're not [ __ ]
he's not a director and my point was
like you don't have to be a director to
be a storyteller or in this case as the
term said filmmaker and so then they do
voting at the end and stuff so Scorsese
Dan did not win was Chris a Z it was
close between me and Elijah but then
Elijah wound up winning and stuff so he
got the first point so you know I still
made a good showing no even Elijah was
like that's impressive I was like I
could [ __ ] anything so round two
what comic book movie of our time will
be most celebrated in 50 years that was
the second question and so they let me
see what they picked Elijah picked the
Dark Knight Dan picked Wonder Woman
I picked guardians of the galaxy and I
argued that guardians of the galaxy
quite like you know Wizard of Oz a movie
that still plays today 50 years
livermore later takes you on a journey
takes you someplace shows you that you
know you can't do it alone you need
friends you lean on each other and stuff
like this what does the movies supposed
to do if not transport you and show you
a different world make you forget things
big you forget your problems and look
yet give you a little moral life lesson
that you could take on into your own
world and stuff while entertaining you
at the same time that's what that movie
does and stuff so we went back and forth
and and like you know my point about
Dark Knight was like Batman is a product
of his error like we change Batman's
within every error so even though we all
love The Dark Knight right now you know
give it twenty years people might be
like oh it's can't be like that old Adam
West version and [ __ ] like that like
he's a product of whatever Ares and I
don't know how that movie I'm sure it's
going to be watchable as [ __ ] 50
years but I don't know if it is as well
as something like guardians of galaxy
and I think it came down to me and Dan
and then I won that one
so that was my round there round three
scariest movie seen all time Lajja pick
some [ __ ] I've never seen before in my
life look like a black and white German
blood corn stroke video and
was the guy just sitting there going
like this stabbing at his stomach with a
[ __ ] knife and [ __ ] and really
scratchy black and white and then it cut
to a close-up and there's blood in his
gut and so this is weird but his
argument was like that I never finished
that movie I'd turn it off it was so
terrifying stuff but most of us felt it
looked like a spank video and so Dan
picked Janet Lee in the shower scene in
psycho and went into a great explanation
evident stuff but then I dropped the
hammer because he was like that could
happen to anybody and stuff you're in
the shower you shower all the time I
could always happen to you my point to
Dan was like lock the [ __ ] door [ __ ]
like psychos a whole different movie if
she locked the [ __ ] door you know so
I said no I said look not everyone needs
to take shower life some people take
bath so you might not even have that
[ __ ] moment I said but everybody in
this life walks around and whenever you
walk around in life there's chances that
you're going to walk around a corner and
if you walk around a corner man there's
nothing more terrifying than seeing two
dead girls holding hands go and come
play without standing so I put up the
shining moment and [ __ ] won the house
easily everyone was like he's [ __ ]
right so I let them know they asked me
for that in advance and you gotta give
answers so that you don't double up so
this person doesn't say this you don't
tell them what you're going to say but
like these are the titles so for round
for the question was if you could
permanently erase one movie from all of
existence which would it be now I
couldn't honestly think of a movie to
erase like I didn't send them that
answer and they kept sending me like hey
you missed four and I just didn't
respond because I didn't have an answer
is like which way to go the obvious way
to go is to like cop out and name one of
my movies or something like that what I
honestly didn't feel that way but I was
like but at the same time it might win
the room and [ __ ] but I was like wow I'm
not going to say I don't know and then I
tried to think of other movies I've seen
in my life that maybe I didn't like and
[ __ ] but I couldn't I couldn't fall upon
one so I kept that blank throughout the
whole show and then like about 30
seconds before it was my turn to
announce a movie I go oh I [ __ ] know
what it is
so I wait for those two dudes to go Dan
picks jaws - and his thought is is the
argument is this he goes jaws - is the
first sequel kind of first time they
were like hey let's put a two in the
title and we'll just tell the whole
story again and she's just more the same
and stuff and he goes you know his logic
was if you stop jaws - you don't get to
like transformers 3 so good logic so
Elijah uh picked Tim Burton's remake of
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
Charlie talked about whoever they called
the movie you know he his argument was
like Gene Wilder's version was
perfection about joy and hope and to
imagination and this was the opposite of
that and stuff and his arguments were
coherent he's wonderful that lies if
nobody else can Elijah would man that's
what I said he's so he's so [ __ ] he
argued so passionately with these big
blue eyes and stuff and you just want to
pick him up and save him from [ __ ]
Gollum and [ __ ] like that
such a good dude so he's sitting there
talking about like Willy Wonka and he's
not like even even as he's saying this
movie doesn't have a right to exist and
stuff he's not you don't feel like he's
attacking Depp or anybody and it or even
Tim Burton it's just this is the movies
picked but as he's talking that's when
it hits me I was like oh I know exactly
how to win this game it's about to
dispatch strategic so they both gave
their titles and then Andy's like keV
what's your title and I said um I'm
going to go with Leni Riefenstahl
triumph of the will because that was the
movie that was made for Hitler to
glorify Nazis
[Laughter]
and I believe that puts me in checkmate
because I don't see how either of you
could argue against that but give it a
shot you know and Elijah was just like
no way you're right you're right and dad
god bless him goes well not wait a
minute and he starts talking about it
he's gone but John's too and he used the
line that was the joke he was the one
that was like if we don't if without
Jaws - you never get to like
transformers 3 and [ __ ] like that
and I go you're absolutely right and
that was worth 6 million live and so I
handily won movie fights they gave me
the [ __ ] trophy i guilted everyone
into a win I was like you can ever
forget ladies and gentlemen at comic-con
and they had a good time this evening
give it up for the man who sits beside
me the guy who they should be hiring
over there both Marvel and [ __ ] DC
studios mr. mark barnard ladies you guys
with a peg and that has been Batman on
Batman for this week I'm Kevin Smith I'm
mark barnard come back next week same
bat-time same bat-channel SModcast calm
or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith tonight
San Diego
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]